let me ask a question how long do you
think it should take from
a person to walk into a gun store
buy a semi-automatic weapon with a
magazine and bullets how long do you
think it should take
a thorough background check whatever
that takes and i you know i'm not expert
in that but i think a thorough back
chair listen
i mean come on kid walks in at 22 years
old where's your mom and dad
you're 21 where's your mother and father
how did you grow up i want to know about
this kid
because again he's got his phone he's
who knows what the situation is with him
he's irresponsible to begin with
i mean my son you know had two two duis
before he was 23 24 years old i wouldn't
put a gun in his hands and i know he
wouldn't shoot anybody he's not that
type of kid but still you were
irresponsible enough to get a dui
you know
how long do you think it should take how
long things should take weeks oh really
yes seriously yes and you're a
conservative saying i am how long do you
think you should take
well not a day whatever's
whatever they're able to pass that's
longer than whatever the current okay
can you can you this this is what i did
four years four and a half years ago
five years ago
in dallas uh can you can you bring that
up kai just make the video bigger and i
want to see if you can see this okay
we're at the store right now we're about
to walk in to buy a semi-automatic
weapon let's see how long it takes by
the way i'm in the city of
plano texas mario can you give me your
phone i want to show exactly what time
it is
it is monday march 26th
11 40 a.m okay
terrible comparison but let's go see how
long it takes us to buy this
semi-automatic weapon
watch this
all right here's your um
can you open this all right so here's
our weapon
here's
the magazine that by the way this
magazine is not a line in the state of
california
this is a time 11 59. so as you can see
you can pause it 19 minutes
what do you think about that
i think it's wrong
you know it's a semi-automatic weapon
yeah 19 minutes to me
so okay when i talk to uh uh uh i'm
conflicted with this so i like the
banter going back and forth so for me on
the one side they're like pat what if we
did the government turns against and
they they're they're coming after you
don't you want to be able to have the
citizens have access to go get a gun
okay all right fine so that's your fear
no it's a right it's an alien you know
it's a right of mind that's in the
constitution second amendment they can't
take it away from me fine
got it okay but 19 minutes you want the
average person to get 90 yeah
i said so how long does a prescription
drug background check take
to see what you're on okay i i if you
want to buy a pistol
okay fine maybe let's make the argument
that you can buy the pistol you want to
get an m16 it's not a it's not an
automatic weapon it's a semi it's a big
difference okay fine no problem
but should you have access to you know
all the stuff that to be able to get it
that quickly why not do why not take a
week why not take two weeks no but if
something happens we have to okay
so no matter where i'm going with this
you get to a point you're like i don't
know
if i want just anybody off the street to
be able to go get this
there's got to be something where i if
you're on a certain medication we're
talking mental health i'm not
comfortable i agree you know i'm just
not comfortable now
to the the guy in uvalde that did what
he did his background was clear he
didn't have any issues he was 18 years
old when he bought it and then while he
didn't do you know he bought it and he
went and did it he didn't do the next
day was weeks later after he bought it
so that still would have allowed him to
go do what he did because
even if you change it to two weeks that
still doesn't so again you go back and
forth with this debate to say how many
of these 246 mass shootings would have
been eliminated based on changing the
last two ages and you come down to only
five percent
so even with the new you understand what
i'm saying so even with
all the new things let's make it 21
let's make it 18 let's make even with
that less than five percent of those
could have been eliminated
so your 246 becomes what 230
okay whatever the number is 230 230 so
yes it may be a good publicity stunt to
do this but i'm looking for real
solutions what is the real solution
on what to do with this part you talk
about single family households america
is the the number one country in the
world for the most single parents look
at this percent this is from pew
research pew research is not fox or uh
or cnn can you make it a little bit
closer kai zoom in a little bit more so
we can see that yeah so according to
peer research the us has the highest
rate of single parenting in the world in
2018 almost a quarter of u.s children
under the age of 18 lived in a household
with a single parent and no other adult
present other than adult children being
a single parent predominantly affects
mothers around the world the u.s around
20 children but their mothers are on
five percent
go go up to show the statistic
go up to show the statistics 49 percent
of what is uh 49 and 20 49 of black
children in the u.s lived with one
parent
as did 28 of hispanic kids and 21 of
white kids go show up look at that chart
right there adam look at that
this is not a leader's bulletin you want
to be number one in
so again even though i did that social
experiment that we did four or five
years ago
that would have still only prevented
five to ten percent of it so
what is the solution to this you know is
this just something for people to change
past some lawsuits say well look at this
we got a victory we passed this
dude you're still gonna have 230 of
those shootings yeah but it goes back to
exactly what i said no it's not the one
solution alone is not raising the age
limit and doing a background check
that's not the the one solution the
solution i mean what do you do do you
call child services and go to the kid's
house and talk to his mother and his
grandmother whoever he was living with
see if he has a
you know i mean how far
how far of a background search do you do
on someone that's why i think you've got
to raise the age limit that's number one
a kid at 18 years old should not have
you know a weapon like that what is he
doing what you got it for tell me why
you could go and buy a gun that quickly
but it's going to take you three more
years to go sit down at your local pub
and legitimately buy a beer how does
that make any sense it makes no sense
and there's certain states where i think
you need to be 21 to even just buy some
marijuana
yes look
do i agree that the second amendment
should exist and we should americans
should be able to have guns yes it's
second amendment like no matter what you
say it is the second amendment but
nowhere in the second amendment does it
say you should be able to get a gun in
less than 10 minutes in a day right it
doesn't say that
so
the the
the straw man of like well they're gonna
come take my guns uh i gotta be able to
protect myself from the government it's
like really you think that you're gonna
protect yourself from the government
come the swat team comes after you okay
best of luck
but there needs to be some some
regulations and some rules around what
i'm saying to you is
even if we follow all the logic which
makes sense it's still only going to be
five percent of it would have been
prevented
so
even if you're 18 to 21 fine i i can go
there and say you want you don't trust
me to drink alcohol you trust me with a
gun that's an easy three second argument
so they're gonna have to come up well
yeah but the military's 18 yeah but even
in the military i didn't sleep with my
gun yeah i always had to turn in my gun
after i'm done shooting congratulations
you're in the military you're allowed to
use the gun and if you're not in the
military you got to wait three months
but even in the military the gun is not
with you it goes back in the safe that
you have to sign in and sign out but all
i'm saying to you is
even if we take your
approach on what you're saying
even if we do all these things that
mcconaughey is saying still only going
to say five percent of them but pat
even if it saves five percent that's x
amount of lives but you're saying but
you know what don't no i i want to push
the limit to challenge us to think about
a better permanent solution i agree to
me
to me this is a systemic issue
this is a
education this is a all-around cultural
issue of who we admire and who we turn
into heroes
that's the issue
kids want to become a hero kids
everybody no matter how old you are what
color you are
what level of education if everybody
wants to be somebody in life
so that somebody isn't being the next
great basketball player
everybody wants to leave a legacy behind
everybody does from the smallest
ambitious person to the most ambitious
person everybody wants to leave some
kind
this this has to be presented at this is
not a way to be a hero
here's why
parents need more training
marriages need to be more
faith values principles i don't care if
you're seven-day
jehovah christian judaism catholic i
don't care what you're practicing go
to somewhere where they're you know
selling
forgiveness you know like the messaging
of forgiveness you take all everything
with faith take the individual out take
abraham out take el ron hubbard out take
jesus out take moses out take take all
these people out right the personality i
don't think he's a real guy fine take
all that stuff out
write a summary on the bible write a
summary on you know old testament write
a summary and like bullet points what
are they teaching us
forgive here it is the neighbor this you
know
adultery this wife this you know with
friends visitors okay
mother this protect your hearts
just put those values and principles
what's wrong with that
the problem to me isn't freaking
increasing the age the problem to me is
we are no longer selling the values and
principles that made america such a
great country where people around the
world wanted to come and raise their
families here
that's the permanent problem adam and i
think that's what we're having issues
with when's the last time you saw
somebody like even
when's the last time you saw somebody on
fox or or msnbc or cnn just praying
when's the last time say hey i just
wanna do a prayer can we do a prayer
here's what i want to pray and you pray
for peace you pray for forgiveness you
pray for you know improvement you pray
for love you pray you i again i don't
this is boring stuff
none of us wanted to hear this stuff
from our parents when we were kids none
of us wanted to hear but guess what
those who did benefited from it those
who didn't didn't benefit from it
so that's what i'm saying where i'm not
looking for like hey let's just pass
it's only going to affect five percent
but i think you're what you're saying is
you there needs to be some action steps
here because thoughts and prayers alone
aren't going to get this no no no but
patrick just he just confirmed my
argument i'm gonna tell you something
very personal
my mother got pregnant when i was fit
when she was 15 years old i was born
when she was 16 years old
my grandmother
because we lived in an italian
neighborhood in brooklyn was so
embarrassed that my mother had a child
out of wedlock that she wanted my mother
to abort me
my grandmother did
which was not uncommon back then you
didn't have a child out of wedlock
my grandmother forced my mother and this
is the story my mother told me patrick
and i i can reveal it now
um
that she got pregnant with my father
sonny but my father was married at that
time okay he couldn't get a divorce
because divorces weren't allowed at that
time in the mob wasn't allowed to do it
my grandmother forced my mother to marry
someone just so that it would appear
that she was married when i was born
right
the point being is the the morality back
then you didn't have a child out of
wedlock it was the wrong thing to do
you jus you just said it
teach the parents what parents
there's usually one person
if you do a study on all of these kids
and i think i think i read something i'm
not sure but most of these mass
shootings were were done by kids that
were between the ages of 20 and 26
something like that i'm not positive but
i think that's what i heard
okay if you go into the background of
these kids i guarantee you're going to
see it as a messed up family or no
family life at all
so that's the root of the problem how do
you change that
when you're giving contraceptives to
kids when they're 9 10 12 or whatever it
is you know in high school without the
parents knowledge it's okay you don't
even have to ask so these kids are
having sex oh it's no problem now go get
an abortion so you abort you know 300
000 babies a year through planned
parenthood but this is all okay it's a
breakdown in morality so yes i agree
with you you know maybe you save five
percent but you got to do something
it's almost like you're working
but yeah you're right but you're almost
like working backwards i don't think so
i don't think so like for example like i
i again
guys please push back like if you if i
have a leak in my argument
identified so for example like you know
how they're saying well you know let's
let's cancel school debt
no
i don't think that's the right but we're
making progress no we're not why not
because
college twitch inflation has increased
200 in the last 40 some years college
tuition has increased 1200 percent
education hasn't improved a thousand
percent no
what about we lower tuition
okay
your salary in the last four years has
only gone from twenty two thousand
dollars to forty some thousand dollars
it's only gone up a hundred twenty
hundred thirty percent college has gone
up twelve hundred percent no before you
cancel college yet i'm for it let's
cancel college tuition
a day after we forced these universities
that are the big capitalists to decrease
their tuition by 80 percent why don't we
do that i'm for it why don't you take
away their tax exempt stuff yeah why
don't we do that so why don't we take
away their taxes why should they be if
you want to take away their tax exempt
do that then the next day i'm all in for
cancelling all the school debt i agree
i'm with that no no no no we can't do
that because you don't want to hold the
institutions that give you that
certificate
that for 40 years you've been bragging
about how big of a deal that piece of
paper is no no
you have to say that because you're part
of that gang so so for me when we're
talking about well like levi just
commented right armenian guy and he says
uh he says as in armenia we mourn on
april 24 due to a government in 1908
that took away our guns from people then
killed one and a half million armenians
750 000 assyrians 500 000 greeks that's
why we need firearms and lots of them
levik i'm saying to you i want more
people to be trained i would love 100 of
americans to be trained on how to use
guns who are not on medication who are
not dealing with mental health who have
a good background in the past that's
been cleared up i'm okay with them so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]